hop
[Musique]
ce lundi 16 août plus de 228 réunionnais
ont repris le chemin de l'école au
collège célimène gaudieux à la
saline-les-hauts la rentrée s'est
déroulée en présence de plusieurs
invités de marque tels que le préfet le
président du département et la rectrice
[Musique]
de nombreux travaux de rénovation ont
été menées par la collectivité
départementale dans cet établissement
c'est important que le département
s'engage comme toujours de quoi faire en
sorte que les jeunes réunionnais
puissent bénéficier des meilleures
conditions d'accueil et d'enseignement
ici à célimène gaudieux par exemple de
l'oua travaux d'amélioration été engagé
près de 7 millions de travaux et au delà
de ça on voit l'engagement de toute
l'équipe pédagogique pourra faire que
les élèves en parfois qui remporte cette
en difficulté et bien soient accueillis
dans les meilleures conditions et
puissent bénéficier du meilleur
enseignement une rentrée aussi placée
sous le signe de l'inclusion à travers
la visite de la classe ulis unité
localisée pour l'inclusion scolaire sa
section d'enseignement général et
professionnel adapté la sec pas fait
également la fierté du collège paix
alors l'inclusion en fait ce sont des
élèves que nous accueillons en classe du
lycée en classes segpa qui ont soit un
handicap soit une notification de la
mdph ses élèves ont une ondée professeur
attitré une coordonnatrice pour les ulis
mais par contre sont intégrés dans
toutes les autres classes c'est à dire
qu'ils sont intégrés avec les classes de
6e 5e 4e 3e générale selon les
disciplines selon les bruits et
compétences des élèves mais aussi selon
leurs possibilités moteur ce qu'on peut
avoir des élèves qui sont handicapés
physiquement et comme on peut avoir des
élèves malentendants et ils ont tous une
accompagnantes
scolaire handicap donc qu'on appelle une
ars h pour les accompagner dans la vie
quotidienne au collège et aussi pour les
aider en classe jacques billant préfet
de la réunion se réjouit que la rentrée
scolaire ait pu se tenir à la date
prévue malgré la crise sanitaire
actuelle ce matin on a on a eu
effectivement des et qui on a vu des
équipes engagées des équipes passionnées
présenter le projet dans lequel les
élèves vont s'inscrire tout au long de
l'année donc
satisfaction confiance et sérénité voilà
comment j'ai ressenti cette map première
matinée de rentrée scolaire en ce lundi
16 août le président du département
souhaite à tous les élèves de l'académie
de la réunion une belle rentrée scolaire
bonne rentrée des classes tout est plein
réussi à vous chers enfants de la
réunion
[Musique]